Welcome to the second problem of Unit 3.
If you thought that the whole situation has started to look grim in the last problem
when we dealt with waning immunity, this time circumstances had become even more dire.
There's no immunity at all.
And so with the typical SIR model, people simply switch back and forth
between susceptible and infected.
We're assuming that more people are lost in the scenario.
So that means that the total number of people which I'm going to call N stays constant.
Since every person is either in the S group or the I group, we know that in any given moment S+I=N.
Here once again are the standard SIR model equations.
You'll need to change this which reflect the new situation
similar to what you have to do in the last problem.
Start by reducing this system at differential equations
to a single equation that contains only I and N but not S.
Then solve this equation numerically using the trapezoidal method,
which in case you forgot I will show you right now.
Remember that the trapezoidal rule finds the value of a quantity after an additional time step
by taking their original quantity and adding to it h times the average
of its rate of change at the two points in consideration.
Now use notation here that probably make sense but just to be clear
x sub-n is just equal to x measured at the n time step
and x do- n is just equal to the time derivative of x at the n time step.
Now once you go through using the trapezoidal method, I want you to solve for S
and then convert your equations for I and S into Python.
Right now the supplied code contains expressions for S and I
that come from the forward Euler method.
Before you fill in the program with the trapezoidal rule run it as it is right now.
Try it first with h set to 10 as it is here and see what happens then change h to equal 0.5,
run the program, and compare the difference between the plots.
When you change the code as we've asked you too, see how each of these
step sizes works with the trapezoidal method instead.
After you're done with everything, set h to 10 and press submit.